Hello, everyone.
[gasps]
Frederick!
Beatrice.
May I present Miss Celery Savoy
and her bow-wow, Dumpling.
And may I make
the further announcement
that we are engaged...
in...
a soon-to-be-married
agreement.
[dramatic music]
[laughing]
♪ ♪
Celery [bleep] Savoy
is the President
of the Clambake Club.
It is unbelievable that a sack
of stupid like Frederick
was able to pull
in a human diamond like Celery.
It's like catching
a golden lobster
with a trap made of shit.
Welcome
to the family, Celery!
Congratulations, Frederick.
You've become another cog
in the great marriage industry.
Well, that is very generous
of you to say,
especially since you will never
know the joy of human touch.
Pardon me, Frederick.
I'm afraid
I may not have heard you.
Would you mind re-describing
the nature of your relationship
with Celery?
Well,
it's like my Freddy said.
We're to be married.
Oh, yes.
That's what I thought he said.
I was just a little distracted
by this buzzing in my head
and hot numbness covering
my body and time slowing down.
(Dodo)
Frederick!
Uh, uh, I...
I have the most tremendous urge
to make water.
- Oh.
- I-I can't--
[all gasp]
[urine trickling]
That's not
a toilet, Mother!
That's my new best friend!
I'm sure I'm pleased
to make your acquaintance.
(man)
♪ I want the money,
I want the fame ♪